donc voilà valérie s'endort mon nom
kiri et
je me retrouvais avec l'honneur de
commencer cette conférence ted
alors voilà le matériel qui arrive si tu
pouvais me brancher sa à la place des
aires c'est donc voilà les explorateurs
du monde moderne
alors moi si on m'a invité ici c'est que
je suis un explorateur du son alors
j'utilise des voies d'exploration qui
sont pas très commune c'est-à-dire
principalement le circuit bending qui
consiste de base à modifier des jouets
pour enfants pour ancrer des sources
sonores complètement particulière à
chaque jouet et qui surprennent à chaque
fois quand on construit le jouer donc ça
le principe c'est de démonter le jouer
d'aller trifouiller un peu dans le
circuit imprimé à l'intérieur avec les
doigts on y va carrément comme on est
sur pile on cherche et il faut contacter
qui vont faire que le son va évoluer va
changer et une fois qu'on trouve ces
choses-là on installe ce qu'il faut des
petites choses électroniques pour fixer
ses effets parce qu'on peut appeler ça
des effets du coup et du coup se crée
des sources sonores très particulière
donc l'exploration alors suivez bien mon
laser c'est important pour être précis
voilà alors qu'est ce que c'est
l'exploration n'en vouliez pas alors je
vais essayer de régler un peu voyez pas
bras on revient on y reviendra à la fin
donc je vais vous faire écouter un petit
premier jouet c'est l'heure du concert
voiliers sont là juste apprendre et
jouer je me sens et donc on peut
s'amuser à changer et sont comme ça
après on peut s'amuser à jouer un petit
peu avec
voilà donc c'est le genre de choses
qu'on peut faire on peut essayer se
jouer par exemple qui lui à l'origine
maintien il n'aime plus j'ai coupé suis
l'un des celui-là qui ne veut plus
allumés donc vous voyez ça ce sont les
sonorités de base que tout le monde
connaît au moins ceux qui ont des
enfants
si je change des sonorités ça peut
donner
voilà une belle basse
et là vous voyez que c'est plus du tout
les sonorités d'un jouet classique et ça
devient réellement un instrument alors
si on s'amuse par exemple sélectionner
la mandoline qui à l'origine est comme
ça si je l'en clanche mais une sonorité
et je peux m'amuser à changer la taille
sur du fond
ouais donc à partir de ces de ces
sources sonores que je crée donc là on
est vraiment dans l'exploration dans
l'exploration on ouvre le jouet on
cherche on se dit ah tiens ça c'est pas
mal couplées d'accès à ces c'est pas mal
et on en arrive à un certain résultat où
on est satisfait on ferme le jouet et
voilà ça nous donne une source sonore
le problème pour faire de la musique
puisque le but principal c'est de faire
de la musique c'est que avec cet
ensemble
voyez c'est compliqué il ya plein de
fils garder tout seul c'est compliqué eh
ben il faudrait 10 bras pour faire de la
musique parce que on peut pas avoir les
doigts partout sur tous les jouets donc
j'en suis venu à la conclusion qu'il
fallait que je séquence s'est joué donc
pour les séquences et les séquences et
c'est à dire leur donner des ordres dans
le temps précis comme une boîte à
rythmes et qui soit entre eux
synchronisée donc qui créé un orchestre
entre eux et qu'il se passe des choses
entre eux eh ben c'est du coup ce que
j'ai créés grâce à principalement de
l'open source
donc des logiciels qui sont des
logiciels et du hardware dont des choses
physiques qui sont en open source c'est
à dire que les gens qui les créent donne
à tout le monde
les sources de leurs codes et de leurs
schémas voilà
je leur dis donc moi je citerai un petit
système
donc si on voit alors donc là c'est bon
set up avec les jouer maintenant ça
c'est le logiciel qui me sert à
séquencer tout ça qui s'appelle pure
data donc pure data vous voyez c'est un
petit peu compliqué il ya plein de fils
il ya plein de boîtes plein de films on
sait pas et ça c'est simple c'est à dire
que ça c'est par exemple la partie vous
voyez à gauche je peux vous montrer avec
le laser
voilà cette partie là et bien cette
partie là si on rentre dedans c'est ça
et tout ce que vous voyez là c'est que
des partis comme ça ou quand on les
ouvre sa devien ça c'est un
développement rhizomique on appelle ça
c'est à dire qu'on va pas partir d'un
point particulier mais de plusieurs
choses en même temps qui au fur et à
mesure on se relier et c'est comme ça
qu'on va explorer un peu ce qu'on peut
faire ensemble donc
trêve de bavardages je vais vous montrer
vous faire une petite démo de ce que ça
peut donner
avec des jouets modifiée et une boîte à
rythme modifié qui permet d'avoir une
certaine structure à l'ensemble c'est
donc parti
alors j'ai trouvé ici
voilà la boîte à rythmes moi qui joue
tranquillement je veux commencer à lui
envoyé des notes sur un jouet qui est
celui ci les notes on commence à
entendre et du coup ça me permet de
caler les jouets et de les faire jouer
en rythme donc là je vais faire un
rythme très bon voilà donc ça c'est un
petit jouet mcdo qui en plus de là que
j'ai remis dans un boîtier ça commence à
s'animer ensemble on les la joue
ensemble on va se mettre une petite
place
donc vous rappeler c'est lui
donc on laisse s'animer choses ensemble
et quand je dis on la seule scène mais
choses ensemble c'est quand même des
jouets
quand on les modifient ils partent
complètement ouvriers donc on peut
s'amuser aussi avec ça par exemple
vous voyez il jouit henry
bon
maintenant que dc jouer ensemble
et maintenant on peut les laisser jouer
tranquillement on peut s'amuser un peu
être d'abord tahri
il
donc voilà pour la petite démonstration
du séquenceur de jouer laisser continuer
hop voilà tout tient là dedans petites
choses que je rends il ya plein de fils
regardez-moi ça là donc ça c'est une
petite carte qui s'appelle ardue noki
open source voilà un logiciel open
source des jouets que je récupérer en
douce ou deux euros en braderie une
boîte à rythme que j'ai eu à 20 euros
par braderie le petit jouet là que j'ai
trouvé dans une poubelle
voilà on arrive des coups à se créer
quelque chose en explorant arriva à
composer quelque chose puisque au final
c'est de faire de la musique de
transmettre des émotions voilà donc
qu'est ce qui est important là dedans
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir
pourquoi c'est possible tout ça alors
est ce que vous vous rappelez de du
fameux blazers alors qu'est ce qui est
important là dedans qu'on voit tous ses
fils
quand on voit quand on voit cette
complicité la ses fils aussi ce qu'il ya
d'important là dedans c'est de faire des
liens de faire des liens entre les
choses différentes qui ne sont pas
forcément centralisée voilà donc de
récupérer des choses des idées tout
autour de nous et grâce à la communauté
donc là entre autres open source mais il
n'ya pas que les communautés open source
par la communauté pouvoir à prendre soin
mer grâce aux autres et une fois que
c'est arrivé de pouvoir transmettre à
son tour une fois qu'on a créé tous les
liens nécessaires à ce qu'on voulait
faire
voilà donc ce projet que j'ai finalisé
que je
sur lequel je bosse depuis deux ans que
j'ai finalisé la semaine dernière en
résidence et bien ce projet là je vais
le sortir en open source pour que les
gens qui font du circuit bending n'est
pas ces deux ans que j'ai passés à
développer le truc
s'ils veulent s'amuser avec donc du lien
voilà entre les choses entre les gens du
lien social
ou alors vous remercie